what can I say guys what an incredible
morning Metallica we hail you guys
you're terrific thank you so much lots
of love thank you to you both until the
restroom out there Richard always comes
in his pants when we have those guys on
I was talking to him last night we were
on the phone and he's like he worships
Lars of course he's a drummer Howard I'm
gonna [__] cry now that was [__]
awesome I mean what you got out of them
I have never heard them talk like that
to anybody like the detail about their
songs and about their instruments
[__] that was awesome Howard thank
you thank you so much and thank you
Robin did you see the Kirk playing that
Wawa pedal yeah I mean he was playing
everybody yeah I mean it's and Laura's
like Laura's playing the drum beat from
one like that song means so [__] much
to me like that song taught me how to
play double bass so it's it was
incredible Howard thank you thank you
thank you
it was something to watch those guys it
really it was yeah yeah incredible I've
never heard them get into detail like
you got out of them hour it was like a
master class and songwriting and and
just the songs that I grew up on when
the guys were saying Metallica belongs
to everyone do you think Metallica
belongs to Fred
laughs
that's up to Fred it seems like they're
playing better than ever to me and I
love that they're new songs like luxa
Turner is fast like that like they're
not slowing down they're they're doing
the music that they did when they were
in their 20s
don't you want to pull your pants off
when you hear this I'll let you pull my
pants down
who are you asking right all right take
it easy I don't want to see that you
could stick your fist up Richard's ass
he's like yes let's build a whole show
around that Robin let's do a big build
up at Madison Square Garden Richard go
beat off
I'm gonna go cry some more that was
awesome